a fancier move right but it's not
something that I would think is too
crazy like I don't this is like watching
sports highlights but we don't get to
watch some highlights
are you ready
it's like let us watch it I think watch
the video uh here's the video so
actually before
[Music]
all right let me tell you a little story
that you were gonna love uh four years
ago there's a guy named Jack Greener
he's a white belt and he's sparring at a
jiu jitsu uh gym with a guy who's a
second degree black right oh I saw this
no way it's not when they're rolling the
dude suffers a spinal cord injury that
leaves him uh paraplegic
Nick likes these stories
this week did they ask him why he was so
weak
no they didn't ask him why it was so big
so this week the San Diego jury finally
concluded the civil suit and they
awarded him more than 46 million in
Damages
um 46. he has since like recovered it's
like partially partially yeah like he's
like TJ who pays for that hair lies
anymore I don't know I don't know any
Jiu Jitsu gym that got that kind of
money no there is none I don't even know
if Gracie Jiu Jitsu the whole HQ has
that kind of money yeah like how does
that how does that number I get that
he's going through something else I'll
tell you I'll tell you how it breaks
down so uh basically it's 638 000 for
loss of past and future earnings one
point what was he a [__] rocket
scientist he was that's his lifetime
earnings he's like yeah he was a surfing
instructor so he's [__] like 17 an
hour dude it's a sales business though
you could really pump those numbers so
you're probably doing at least 100.3
million for past medical expenses 8.5
million for future medical 11 million
for past pain and suffering 25 million
for future pain and suffering
so I saw the video of it and this is uh
this is a video that all the Jiu Jitsu
authorities and the space really look
down upon because like when you're a
black belt not only are you instructor
but you're kind of like a nurturer of
the environment and of the sport and the
move that he pulled on him it's almost
like kind of like Bully like oh look
what you can do you know it's almost
like LeBron James dunking on like a
third year three-year-old and then so
even a 30 year old's the same way people
are saying that it's like it's kind of a
regular move but it was a free I don't
know man it was one of those moves where
I just felt like oh McDonald's
you gotta take care of them you know
like yeah black belts you can feel them
going I'm getting very close to killing
you but you're you feel so safe versus
if I grapple with a blue belt or a
purple belt they're really trying the
hardest because they know that if they
don't they might lose but a black belt
should be at a level where it usually
feels the safest grappling with the
black belt but then again I'll say this
not all black belts are created equal
and neither are some white belts too so
some white belts they're they're just
kind of to be a [__] dick huh well
they're just kind of like crazy they're
kind of like Spazzy you're gonna get
hurt rolling with a white belt I'm happy
apparently has a really good reputation
though for like being and honestly
seeing the move like yeah it is like a
kind of a a fancier move right but it's
not something that I would think is too
crazy like I don't know this is like
watching sports highlights but we don't
get to watch the highlights
are you ready
it's like let us watch it first I think
watch the video uh here's the video so
actually before
yourself
so he tries to roll over his shoulder
he's trying to take his back and he
rolls over that shoulder right there
right but on his neck and then done
is that a normal thing so he tries to go
off to the side
and then the white belt kind of I don't
know I think he just got stuck he didn't
know where his body was
fully oh there's the neck part
so then his body so that got snapped
with his head stuck on the map he was
trying to seat belt him right so he's
he's grabbing his shoulders like this
yeah so put me a seatbelt Bart what's
his seat is this you know what a seat
belt
grabbing this and then he's trying to
throw his legs over on this side so I do
like a forward roll on the shoulder and
he takes my back yeah dude okay dude now
Nick gets paralyzed yeah I'm dead dude
hey 46 mil baby so here's the Here's the
the video of the guy that um this is the
dude that the black hole got
uh here's his like quote about it he
needs to speak louder
I was doing what I still do every single
day on the mat it's just that that day
turning a terrible outcome and a very
sad story oh I wanted to put out there
that
this was in my intention it wasn't my a
reckless move from my behalf I was just
doing what I still do every single day
and this was a freak accident that sucks
what was the reminder I think that's
spot-on but also too like people forget
like this is
injuries are gonna happen they can't
happen obviously not as catastrophic as
this all the time but you're still
[__] throwing your bones at people I
think his reputation matters a lot so if
everyone goes like he's a very dope dude
and this is freak accent it is but then
if he's also like a [__] Dylan Dan
it's like a yeah like everyone hates his
ass and he's a dumbass dude maybe
there's some Notorious Jiu Jitsu guys
who are world champions at the highest
stage who have schools where their
videos on social media of them marketing
their gym is them slamming people on
their [__] head like like
spiking people yeah dude so it's like
rock and roll music
marketing huh kind of metal bro before
the video came out people were saying
they expected to see like some kind of a
spike me too I did too yeah on the other
side
um and this is actually legit like
victim blaming is legit and Jiu-Jitsu
yeah white belts don't know how to fall
either yeah so me and Jill when we first
started doing Jiu Jitsu I actually broke
her toe and it's because she doesn't
know how to like tuck her feet like
right like let's say if I were to slam
Nick he would know oh she took my
shoulder and I'll just take it into the
mat other people that just start don't
post up and then pop their [__] elbow
out or break her because their white
belts are just dumb you don't know how
to fall or like how to take something
right so is that a result of bad
teaching no no it's just wipeouts are
dumb white belts are dumb that's it but
it's just dumped but yes yes and yes or
no it's both it's it's definitely like
you could teach a lot of the times too
in classes the warm-up is you doing all
these fundamental movement patterns so
you know how to roll you don't have to
break fall you don't have to fall
properly but if it's your first lesson
100 but there are people who go every
day and do all the warm-ups and continue
and the warm-ups are the same every
single day for months on end and they
still don't know how to do it you know I
mean because it's like they still can't
apply it for some reason or they just
maybe there is like a gap that needs to
be fixed it's like people dancing with
two left feet right like what the [__] I
just don't get it it's just in this
there's physical consequences if you
[__] and sometimes it just takes longer
like it might yeah you might suppose
you're supposed to get this in a month
you might it might take you four months
depending on who you're dealing I think
it's just because white belts are dumb
white belts are [__] amount of lights
out too so I'm dumb too like when I when
I grab you you're a champion though when
I grapple with like I gave myself a
stripe that's sick you bought some
electricians tape and did it yeah
when I cropful with um other white belts
the type of injuries that happen is
[__] insane like they're silly
there's [__] shins to the face some
guy cracks his neck for no reason it's
not graceful at all because no one
understands how to move or be athletic
yet versus watching like other the
colored belts they're like like no one's
getting hurt and they're getting a lot
of good training in it's just because
white pills are dumb too that's part of
it it is a challenge training white
balls like it it is a challenge because
you have to understand how to
contextualize like what the end goal is
to them in each position yeah and that's
a lot it's a hard thing to do but you
have to really sit down and explain it
to them like
like spell it out you can't assume that
they understand anything does that look
like a freak accident yeah that's a
purple belt it looks like he should have
made that move which guy they got on top
or bottom both of them
you got to do your forms first you got
to your forms how come there's no jiu
jitsu forms if they only had you had
Juventus you look stupid you're like
yeah
that was a great question Alex dude you
look stupid rolling around the ground
dude you look sick doing for him to
music you look like a break dancer wait
till I grab that chain Steve yeah we'll
see so there's like there's some
comments on here from like different
lawyers in like injury lawyers and
they're kind of breaking down how like
just because you're rewarded 46 million
doesn't mean you're gonna get it a lot
of the time when you're awarded money
for personal injury if there's no way
that the person can pay you you just
will never receive it and in this case
they're like oh but insurance is gonna
pay for it but they're like there's no
way any Dojo or like or Jim has that
much money in Insurance like they were
like I don't even think LA Fitness got
46. Max they would have like maybe a
mill a million comprehensive like
something yeah yeah maybe have a minute
you have to liquidate all the equipment
in LA Fitness and even then you wouldn't
get there a million point two yeah and
they're saying that like you're right on
the parking lot it's very normal for you
to know ever get the money that uh
especially when they can't enforce like
let's say someone actually has that
money the court also can't force them to
always pay you on time either like they
could just not pay you so can it go to
collections so for the rest of this life
this Jiu Jitsu instructor is going to be
paying this guy all his money dating
collections to guy College like you got
the 46 million yet oh what's going on
you don't have a job 43 years later it's
just like hey you got the 45 million
plus I don't think insurance would even
cover it because if it's based on some
kind of negligence that it kind of
eliminates the insurance responsibility
and then you know like waivers don't
they got waivers they'll usually sign a
waiver like if they snap my neck it's my
fault was it a personal suit it doesn't
matter because if you even if you sign a
waiver uh if it's over negligence then
like you can't the waiver doesn't matter
kind of like with with my studio I have
a waiver as well but if I built
something really shitty and it broke and
someone fell it wouldn't matter like
it'd be my fault I see
I don't know that's the thing the Court
ruled in favor of the yeah of the
plaintiff if I was using your studio and
I was like I was like carrying a big jug
of apple juice but I was on roller
skates and I dreamed is that on you if
you tripped and fell because of a design
I made on the ground it would be on me
yeah what about it
what if I was uh only fans man and I was
doing an anal scene with a dildo and
then um I got pre-cum all over the floor
and I slipped and fell right hit my head
on one of your [__] awesome desks
with phones all over it
but the pre-cum was on a design flaw
that he had in the floor exactly that's
the thing he had the linoleum
slick your honor it's not about the
pre-cum
it would be tractioned but you had a
slippy slip linoleum what kind of dildo
was it
a throbbing hard black one yeah I think
it would have to be the the failure of
something that I'd made would have to be
the cause
that's the only thing it's not the
pre-com the not the pre-com now it
doesn't matter how it doesn't matter
doesn't matter how good it tastes
basically all right check this out you
have that phone room right yeah all
right I used I use the phone
shove it up my butthole all right I
didn't enema so a little bit of kaka
juice comes out I slip and fall
and then I fall break my [__] why
don't you just wear shoes it doesn't
matter where you're putting a butt you
won't say you want to stop showing up
naked watch yourself shoving everything
up your ass
I don't think you're allowed to put
anything up your ass that is
I'm using your product why does your
studio have so many things you shove up
your ass one more scenario one more joke
scenario he has a scooter yeah I back my
ass up into his handlebar no enema no
enema Kaka Falls all out I slip and fall
hit my head at the back of the [__]
floor
I sue you for what for gross negligence
your 25 million worth
23 million I don't
wanna I want you to come back
[Music]
all right